actually let me let me just let me see
if i can pull this up and we'll talk
about it we got this tweet from turning
point usa
they say yesterday the view and whoopi
goldberg smeared and lied about tpusa
regarding an incident where supposed
nazis showed up outside the the student
action summit basically they say oh
there were nazis there yeah there were
weirdos waving a flag outside the event
on the public sidewalk folded flags
freshly unfolded yeah yeah
probably probably the left it was yeah
the left created this story i mean then
whoopi goldberg says they were pseudo
over there they were in there she's
forced to come back out and say they
weren't in there but they were uh they
weren't inside the building but you know
they were they were they were mixed in
with the people it's all big it's all
just outright lies
about everything
so oh so instead of the same person who
got in trouble for
what did she say the holocaust wasn't
racially motivated yeah now let me play
this before bad take something let me
play this clip for you real quick and um
avert your ears children this may be
rather shrill and annoying you've been
warned
step up right back
okay
guys
i should kill myself why
why
why should i kill myself
this this young woman screaming
for literally no reason nothing she
understands how do you say to her ma'am
did you know that we can solve the
problem of climate change by mining
carbon from the atmosphere put it in a
song a hit song because that gets the
mindless zombies to dance along perhaps
ian write a hit song called we can mind
graphing from the air
and then these people will start
screaming and then you play the song
no the problem is they you know what i
think the zombie hordes hate they want
to hate they hate
and
it's like that you know that meme where
the guy says i'm angry and the guy says
here's a solution and then he burns and
says i don't want a solution i want to
be mad he's like i'm mad i want to be
mad
this woman's screaming and i got to tell
you i don't know her personally but i
will tell you my experience having been
at these protests there's no reasoning
with these people
none
of them not in the moment for sure but
no no no not just not at all i've been
there i've been to their act i've been
to their meetings
even those are impossible in a in a room
with a bunch of people like good luck no
no no i'm talking about what i'm talking
about possible the private rooms on
occupy wall street where they were
squatting inside one of the buildings
yeah the same team i wonder if we're at
the same meeting maybe even awesome and
everyone's sitting down with in small
groups having conversations and these
people are zealots they don't care they
they you are dealing with ideology
versus
logic and they don't yeah you can't head
on it you gotta sub subvert it and kind
of make them believe it without them
realizing they're believing it which is
why no no no
you misunderstand i agree with you on
that point but what i'm saying is
they want hatred yeah it's addictive and
so if you tell someone i got this really
good idea that we could mine carbon out
of the atmosphere to stop climate change
they would say
i don't care i hate these people i hate
these people hate is like real it's
something that they can like at least
they know they have control of something
as long as they can continue to and when
it goes away then it's this
uncertainty that can lead to like terror
and so they snap back to what they know
that's kind of a natural phenomenon i
just i i was in um san bernardino
there was a group of people protesting
holding up signs
and they had all stopped and they were
talking to each other and i walked up
and i was like how's it going guys and
they just looked at me like some of them
like oh hey what's up and i was like i
just wanted to ask you guys like what's
going on like what are you what are you
doing and then someone walks up and
starts screaming mike jack mike jack
mike check
instantly all of the activists start
repeating in unison might check that's
what you're supposed to do what does
that even mean i don't know what michael
like this mic mic check is a technique
that the activists uh the cults use to
uh
they claim bring them back to the truth
amplify
voices when you can't hear things freaky
weird oh is that where they repeat like
oh my goodness i wouldn't occupy i
wouldn't do it i refused i just screamed
as loud as i could so they didn't have
to repeat me because it was so called it
was called
it's a call to repeat the thing they
make you repeat it several times and so
when i tried talking to people they
immediately start yelling mic check
stopping the conversation and the woman
said she goes do not and they all go do
not and she goes talk to anyone and
they'll repeat talk to anyone they are
trying they are trying to trick you to
trick you and then she says it again and
they all just mindlessly chance you
don't get it man like i hear what you're
saying about subverting and like trying
to convince them but when people are in
a zombie horde controlled by a zombie
lord i don't know what to tell you
because i've been in private with them
and they have cognitive dissonance and
they experience physical pain when you
provide information that could shatter
that and when they're in public they're
unwilling or just so angry look at this
woman she's screaming at drew
hernandez's face for no reason she
doesn't know him know anything about him
and she's saying stand up fight back
what does that mean i want the context
what did drew say do you have is there
more of the video oh i don't have it but
but come on like
no we don't need context i must know we
can see the humanity in the woman you
will
what is your what does stand up fight
back mean
okay what are the rhetoric
what are they what are they protesting i
don't know what is it twitter free
isabel
they're amoral and they want to cling to
something that feels like
a moral system zombies
what makes someone susceptible to that
you know i i
why is it not you
why is it not me i don't know like why
isn't it like not any of us these crowds
yeah um
strong mental fortitude and
independent having a job i don't know
about that
um
i think it's i think it's uh
i don't know if it's
nature or nurture
because i wonder
how is it that throughout my life i have
been fiercely independent maybe it's
maybe it's uh nurture you know the the
way i was raised are you scottish by
chance
no uh part irish okay that might explain
it but uh i'm a bunch of different
things
growing up in on the south side it was
like
you know figure it out it's all you know
maybe that's it maybe maybe these are
kids who had everything handed to them
and they have no idea to solve their
problems i think that could be a big
part of it because there are so many
people who say i don't know what to do
and i'm like i gotta be honest if you
were an adult and you don't know what to
do to be successful then
you prop you did not have parents who
taught you the things you needed to do
to survive or circumstances that did
because i was lucky enough to have a bit
of both i had uh parents who basically
hey get out of the house and go do stuff
and so forcing me to be more independent
that was what we did back then when i
was a kid we be we'd be anti-grounded my
parents would be like get out of the
house like you're sitting inside too
much go do something come back when the
street lights turn on that was that was
me growing up and so
solve your problems you're on youtube i
got uh
we had a house
that didn't have a deck off the sliding
glass door my parents just never put one
on there and they if there's one now
there they're still in the same house
but they um
my mom would just open up that sliding
glass window and yell and whistle the
same way she would call the dog
that was when it was time to come in for
dinner
i mean it was
you know like most of our childhoods it
was like that was just normal i would i
remember i was like i'm like 14 and my
friends were all jumping on the freight
trains and riding them because you know
our area was like from where we lived
where the park was was like three miles
so you'd be walking down the tracks
you'd hear the thing the train's going
like 15 or 20 miles an hour you run and
then just grab and hang on and it brings
you all the way there is there were
little kids doing this stuff yeah
just figure it out on your own i wonder
if these kids don't have that well this
girl
i watched her eyes when she was
screaming it looks like some sort of
amphetamine intercept like it looks like
a federal yeah adderall maybe because
like the eyes are so
round and pupilled and they're not
matching with the mouth
i think kids that like are on drugs
at age 12 13 14 even younger
don't know
how to be happy really or they don't
know what they're protesting yeah they
don't they don't have like a solid
formation of what they think reality is
without the drug
right so there were protesters today
outside the uh marriott marquis oh yeah
how was that
yeah i'm used to it um and i hate to i
hate to say i have one
one rule of protesters
um please write your signs so they can
be read
at about 35 miles an hour because for
some reason jeff sessions when i was
worked with him um
had a lot of people that didn't like him
and had a lot of protesters would show
up everywhere we went around the country
and these people would write these very
convoluted signs that didn't make any
sense i mean there were a couple like
two-word ones like fu like that that
made sense i get your perspective but
remember when someone made a sign that
said rahm emanuel likes nickelback
how dare they and then all of a sudden
everyone started writing similar signs
yeah and became a meme because these
people aren't prosperous
game day's
they're not protesting anything they're
showing up and trying to just be part of
a crowd to feel
included or something so they need to go
to church
right well they don't have this is their
church right yeah that's it which is so
trite to say but it's true it is and so
the funny thing is how
i take a look at this right um i'm
certainly not christian by any standard
i take a look at this and i take a look
at it there's always time well i i was
when i was younger i went to catholic
school and uh i was raised catholic and
then i believe in god but i don't
believe in any of the uh organized
religions for the most part um so you're
spiritual no that's that's not spiritual
yeah he is do you believe in a power
greater than yourself yes okay
um
i think logic you pray
i i think maybe christians would
i don't consider it praying in the same
way that a christian would or someone
else so maybe maybe not i wouldn't say
so but uh when i when i stand back and i
see
modern christianity i see some people
who believe stupid things i see some
people who think there's a giant man in
a row bald in the clouds who's watching
over us which is silly but then i see
people who are um
more uh learned when it comes to
philosophy and theology and they
actually question and they have um
legitimate reasons for believing the
things they do
but more importantly i say okay let's
talk about the the general outcome of
what we have were there bad things
before uh modernization and reformation
oh you betcha and there still are a lot
of religions but i tell you this when i
go down
i was hanging out with sheamus who's a
catholic and we went down to uh
charlestown after after we met up with
him after mass got out i see a bunch of
little kids playing wearing nice clothes
with their parents and their parents are
keeping their kids safe and they're
sharing food with the needy and things
like that i'm like all those things are
really good you want to have a gathering
and your idea of doing right by your
community is teaching your kids to be
good people and providing food to the
needy i'm like dig it really great
if your idea of a gathering in community
building is screaming at the top of your
lungs and throwing bricks and harassing
people we got a very serious problem
with your moral framework
so what do we see right now perhaps
there will be a reformation of leftist
ideology in 2000 years and they'll
realize that maybe they should actually
practice what they preach and instead of
screaming in people's faces and throwing
bricks at them they give them bread a
lot of these people do that when i see
people doing like foods not bombs giving
out food i've seen this my entire life
that's fantastic if that's your idea of
organizing that's great
and then of course there you know
historically there have been you know
bad christians as well
modern times right now i'm not going to
sit here and complain about the 50s
you know those times have passed civil
rights won congratulations my family's
certainly happy that it happened now i'm
looking at
your average christian and um
maybe not doing enough to raise their
kids properly and so this is why you're
seeing a wave of young people
becoming dejected and lost
but i see at these universities some new
kind of pseudo-non-theistic religion in
critical theory wokeness
i don't think any of these one terms
defines what's happening they say
intersectional feminism they say
wokeness they say critical race theory
critical gender theory critical theory
none of those things actually explain
what we're seeing the emergence of a
non-theistic religion perhaps wokism is
the best all-encompassing term these are
people who have all of the similar
traits of a newly formed religion or
dogma they are violent they are angry
they have no rhyme or reason or logic
behind what they do is this
transhumanism do you think this is a
transhumanistic religion no it's almost
like um the way i explained it before is
i read a physics book about uh when they
captured electrons in a two-dimensional
plane and simulated a an element
so an element for instance has got like
a hydrogen has an atomic weight of one i
believe yeah one proton one proton with
an electron
orbiting it so what i read was that in a
two dimensional plane they captured an
electron in simulated orbit there was no
proton nucleus but it adopted the
properties of hydrogen because of the
confined space and the forced movement
of the electron or whatever and so they
injected an electron another one into it
and it simulated helium effectively but
there was no core there was no nucleus
and that's what i see here i see
the all of the bad of religion amassed
into one group with no rhyme or reason
or dictating principles just chaos it is
like a fire consuming burning full of
rage and there's no reasoning with it
yeah you do it's like
so they're forcing it's not happening
naturally it's like it's like a forced
um
creation as opposed to happening
naturally
it's like take take a bunch of people
it's it's you know what it is it's
really simple it's uh
take a christian society which the
united states absolutely is and and the
left might be like no we're not i'm not
saying it should be i'm saying that the
overwhelming majority of people in this
country identify as christians and
historically have done so and then what
you do is over time
those kids
the next generations next generations
slowly cease to hold the values
and what you end up with is all that all
of the elements of dogma without any of
the moral framework yeah like when you
tell yourself i i have to go do this
thing because that's what a christian
would do or i have to go yell at a crowd
because that's what a true believer
would do you're the electron without the
core
it comes nat you don't need to be told
what to do to get it done you know it's
it's inherent in the system if you look
around and you're open to it but that
requires
some sort of i don't know stability you
know it's crazy
the the lady from the westboro baptist
church who got de-radicalized on twitter
you know the story oh yeah i can't
remember her name but she was on her
yeah she was on twitter and then people
started having conversations with her
and then she was like wow okay maybe i'm
wrong about this uh daryl davis talking
about how he met with klansmen and then
he's a black man and he talks to him and
then they turn in their robes and say i
don't want to do this anymore
and then you take a look at these people
and they're the complete opposite
there's no reasoning they're just
screaming and dogmatic i think it was
megan phelps roper is the woman that
left the westboro baptist church
yep that was a rogue interview that was
pretty cool i believe that's very cool
yeah
i wonder what this uh
you know watching this video from from
uh uh it's uh front lines with drew
hernandez seeing this video this woman
just screaming and it's just so uh it's
it's exactly what i experienced for a
decade i'm like where did these people
end up i keep thinking of like the
second coming of christ and like how
they say in the apocalypse or the end
times that christ will re-emerge to
unify the planet or whatever i don't
know maybe you know more about it i
don't know but that maybe that's what we
need right now with like obviously islam
and christianity but now this too yeah
well i mean you know obviously
christians including myself believe that
jesus will come again he promised he
would
um you know there's some belief that
he'll come through the east gate uh on
the temple mount i was just there a week
ago he was not there at the time hasn't
been there yet um
well he clearly didn't come to unify as
he said himself
um a lot of us you know our human nature
and human you know just failing i mean
we you know we always
human beings for the you know through to
time and memorium have always you know
sort of put themselves at the center of
the universe i mean this that's why um
i think these pictures from this new um
uh
satellite
that are bringing
you know 150 million years of you know i
have been extraordinary but it just it
points just i mean not only how many
universes there are but just how like
how remote how many universes there are
well not you know i'm sorry
i was like yeah i think you're
channeling the truth there you know
multiverse theory huh
well this is something that i've had
deep conversations with with smart
people and you know at the end of the
day you know physicists can't explain
where we're what it's expanding into
and and it just gets really you know
been the curvatures and things bending
and donuts and all that and and i just i
think these pictures are just
extraordinary because if you look at the
like like a like the size of what was it
the size of like a
pin the head of a pin and it had all of
these galaxies in it now you want to
just it was just and you just think like
you know we're just like on this random
one arm
of one galaxy
uh kind of really sort of out of you
know outside of the middle of all this
it's just absolutely it blows your mind
there's a scary thing about it though
right the universe is expanding things
looking like either yeah i totally agree
i think you're like freaking me out
like there's so much life in the u in
this universe i would imagine there's so
much of us here's a scary thing they say
the universe is expanding and it's
expanding faster right
so that means it looks like it there
will come to a point where
the universe has expanded so much when
you look into the night sky you will see
literally nothing because the light is
moving away from the light that's moving
away from us faster than it can come to
us
people
in that era
will think there is nothing else i think
that's an optical illusion because the
universe is twisting around on itself
you mentioned the donut the taurus and
that because it's because the wavelength
is turning it looks like it's changing
color uh it's called the red shift in
nature it looks and they say well that
means it's getting further away but it
might just be that the
the wave is bending and your it looks
like it's becoming a shorter frequency
or a longer frequency depending on how
it's bending
and um it's just twisting that's uh okay
perhaps thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8 pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm and we'll see you all
there